yassine belattar et où les chenilles se
débattait ce qu'il adore et tu donnes
tout le monde quoi j'adorais toi
isabelle a rappelé un petit truc ça va
ça va très bien monsieur quand on a
survécu à trois guerres way était un
accord hier cyril tu as demandé aux
chroniqueurs quelle est la plus grosse
star qu'ils ont rencontré des réponses
éclectique 2010 nigger m jackson prime
shakira hélène rollès cherchez l'intrus
bon passage préféré hier c'est quand
kahina de la candidate de l'émission et
si on se rencontrait a dit que les
monteurs ont complètement changé sa
phrase ça mais en fait on maintenant de
dire je suis amoureuse mais la phrase
n'est pas donc c'est pas vous la phrase
a été très bon en fait la vraie phrase
ou free je peux pas dire que je suis
encore amoureuse dans et malheureusement
on entend dire je suis amoureuse ah
ouais bah ouais le montage de ces délits
avec le montage on peut faire dire
n'importe quoi n'importe qui par exemple
si je pose la question chroniqueur ici
présents à votre avis si marine le pen
gagnent en 2022 qui sera son premier
ministre
shaquille o'neal naniwa zinger michael
jackson prime shakira hélène rollès
alors
c'est dangereux le montage parce
qu'après c'est le bad buzz qui
commençait après les médias s'emballent
regarder le figaro shakeel o'neal
soutient marine le pen
derrière le nouveau détective en chaîne
nicolas pernikoff mêlée dans la sphère
michael jackson après les magazines
people s'en mêle la une de voici steevy
et il le fils caché d'hélène rollès
cyril hanouna témoigne je savais ce
terreau attention les bad buzz ça arrive
très vite
en deuxième partie d'émission hier vous
avez parlé de deux virus très virulent
en france en ce moment le qu'ovide 19 et
la télé réalité alors lequel des deux
est le plus grave vous pouvez répondre
chez vous à vous de juger
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
alors nous aurons la cmar c'est parce
que je quitte l'émission je te le dis
moi ya six mois j'ai pas en devenir et
je kiffe les mecs qui sont donc ces cd
cd on n est pas tant voilà j'adore on
fera souvent en maillot à la
bibliothèque
jeudi enfin complotistes mais je me pose
quand même la question qui a créé le
coronavirus à je veux un coupable et les
chroniqueurs vont donner leur avis
shaquille o'neal danny way speaker
michael jackson prins shakira hélène
rollès
[Applaudissements]